I'd like to begin this song I wrote
about ceaseless yearning and never-ending want
with a poem of popular Petrarchan paradoxes
by Sir Thomas Wyatt the Elder:
"I find no peace, and all my war is done;
I fear and hope, I burn and freeze like ice;
I fly above the wind,
and yet I cannot arise;
And naught I have,
and all the world I seize upon."
♫ I want what I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have what I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ What I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have ♫
♫ It feels like all I got is loss on a bad back ♫
♫ Gone with the last train, honey don't you fret ♫
♫ Every cloud has a silver lining ♫
♫ Just a little rain, just a little rain, just a little rain ♫
♫ I want what I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have what I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ What I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have ♫
♫ My mind won't stop, and my heart says go ♫
♫ Nobody knows how to hold me ♫
♫ My mind won't stop, and my heart says, ♫
♫ "Good things come to those who wait" ♫
♫ And I can't stand in ... ♫
♫ I can't stand in line forever ♫
♫ Stand the cold air ♫
♫ Glad-handed ♫
♫ Sick and tired of the "Later, maybe" ♫
♫ Take it, fake it, take it, take-it-or-leave-it life ♫
♫ And I gotta just tame it ♫
♫ I gotta just name it ♫
♫ I gotta just seize, so please, oh please, oh please, oh please ♫
♫ Oh please me right, 'cause ♫
♫ My mind won't stop ♫
♫ And my heart says go ♫
♫ Nobody knows how to hold me ♫
♫ My mind won't stop -- and my heart says go-ooooo ... ♫
♫ Good things must be here -- yes, right here ♫
♫ Here, right here, right here ♫
♫ I won't live this life forever ♫
♫ One time round is all the offer is ♫
♫ Sick and tired of the "Later, maybe" ♫
♫ Take it, fake it, make it, leave it life ♫
♫ And I gotta just name it, I gotta just claim it ♫
♫ I gotta just seize ♫
♫ Oh please, oh please, oh please me right ♫
♫ I want what I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have what I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ What I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have -- you know that ♫
♫ My mind won't stop, and my heart says go ♫
♫ Nobody knows how to hold me, no ♫
♫ 'Cause I want what I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I -- have what I want ♫
♫ What I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ Have what I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ What I can't have, need what I can't want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have, what I want ♫
♫ Have but I don't have what I want ♫
(Applause)